now more than 16 million people were
told yesterday to stay at home
and not mix with other households even
on christmas day
and millions of those people are in
london so we're joined now by the city's
mayor
city khan people across london are going
to
be
bitterly disappointed by the news
yesterday but
do you support the decision to ban
household mixing at christmas
i do i'm going to distinguish my views
on the additional restrictions which i
think
are needed and my criticism of the
incompetent way the government's been
handling the
pandemic we've got to recognize this
virus spreading
fast uh six out of ten londoners who
have
the virus have this new strain which
passes much more speedily but also i
checked this morning
and we have the same number of patients
in our hospitals as in patients with
covid
now as we had at the peak in april and
this is the month before
january which is the busiest month of
the year for our nhs nobody wants
the nhs to be overwhelmed uh over the
course of the next few days and weeks
so it's incredible how quickly the
situations change i remember when london
was in tier two it feels like a distant
memory now um
is it fair that people in london have
been told to stay at home
that they can't see their nan that they
have to you know rush out to buy a
turkey that they can't handle the
presents that they've wrapped
while other people across the country
will be able to see their families at
christmas
well there's nothing about this virus
that's fair this virus isn't the great
leveler
it's different community
different ethnicities people in
different jobs in a different way so
it's only
your fairness it's an issue of lack of
clarity and consistency
back in july when the prime minister
said we returned to normality by
christmas
many of us said that can't be right
that's not what the evidence is and that
gave people
false hope and then as recently as
november
the prime minister announced the
restrictions being lifted for these five
days during christmas
three households mixing unlimited
numbers
and we thought that can't be right the
evidence doesn't say so
expectations of a raise as recently as
uh earlier this week
when many of us were saying look it
doesn't make sense london to go from
enforcement to tier two to tier three
effectively reached tier zero over
christmas and then back to tier three
we were accused of trying to cancel
christmas
so the unfairness in relation to
the virus is one we can understand and
except
the is one that isn't acceptable and
that's what's unfair having
boris johnson in charge of this
difficult time a really difficult um
situation for many of us and we've been
talking a lot about at christmas
uh but of course one of the really
significant things is that london's
going to be in tier 4
with these increased restrictions on
what we can do and what businesses can
do on what businesses can open as well
are you concerned about the impact that
that's going to have on london a city
that of course is reliant on tourism
which is reliant on the hospitality
industry and
in which many people of course are
reliant on coming to the offices
in the city centres is tier four going
to have a big
impact on the economy of london
oh without doubt uh this will not just
be the worst christmas
we've had as a city since the second
world war it's the worst year we've had
since the second world
war many of our sectors think of culture
hospitality leisure tourism retail
have suffered in ways they've never
experienced people with many many long
careers
and that's why we've been pleading with
the government for a
roadmap to recovery but also for
additional support our sectors need
to make sure these businesses that have
closed temporarily uh
haven't got permanent closures and it
can
reopen in the new year but also
underwater those who are self-employed
but there are three million people
across our country who have fallen
through the cracks think of those who
are self-employed
those who get dividends as directors
those who are newly self-employed
who have received no assistance these
are
all creators these people the
jobs of london as many across the
country and so i'm pleading with the
government
uh don't turn your back on
these be crucial not just in london's
recovery but to the national recovery
particularly
as we'll have left the european union
completely by johnny the first
there's a few issues with your sound but
we are going to keep going because i
think we can still hear
you know the important things that you
are um saying and one of my main
takeaways from the
interview with matt hancock was him
effectively saying that because tier
three was unable to stop the spread of
this new variant
people in tier 4 should really be
preparing to stay in there
for some months to come and london is
going to be living under tier 4
conditions for months do you think
well i've said for some time the
current tiering system is ineffective
and it isn't working
it's a blunt instrument that doesn't
address the pipeline of the virus being
caused
the reality is we the hospital numbers
we have
are about a two-week lag and the reality
is if january is the busiest month of
the year
year on year the people catching the
virus now
could all be going to hospital in two
weeks time which is why we're so
concerned
the key message i want to get across to
those people who may need nhs care
who want kovi sufferers is please
continue to contact your gp
to ring one one one what we don't want
is a repeat in january what we saw in
march april may where not
uncovered those with cancer those with
respiratory issues
didn't go and receive care because they
were worried it wasn't available
and that's why we're really concerned is
a perfect storm
in relation to the virus spreading fast
six out of 10 londoners having the new
strain
and there being a january where the nhs
could be very
very busy and that's why i think matt
hancock is right to advise caution
i'd rather the government under promised
and over delivered
rather than a prime minister who gives
false
making unrealistic promises that you're
never going to be
do you think um that we should consider
closing schools
in london if the varys rates don't come
down
i completely agree with what lisa was
saying earlier which is that we need to
make sure our children are back at
schools which is the best place for them
but there's a but
i know from the evidence i saw in the
week before schools broke up
that the age group where there was the
biggest increase in the virus was those
aged between 10 and 19 a 75
increase in a week many of these
children were asymptomatic but then
going back home and
giving them the virus to mom and dad
and these same children would have been
hugging granny and grandpa christmas so
what i think
was they should be doing mass testing of
children and
staff staff and teachers heroic efforts
to make our schools
safe but many of our schools aren't
covered safe
if it's the case that some schools have
to reopen a day or two later
to get mass tested in place so be it
we've got to make sure our children are
back school but those schools are
covered safe
safe for our teachers for our staff
children and it's worth reminding
ourselves
the virus in an age group it spreads
rapidly in other age groups
as well across london we're not simply
an increase in the icelandic
headline which is a real source of
concern
okay and thank you so much to be on the
program uh sadiq khan really interesting
to get your take
on the restrictions in london thank you